it's Game one of the Western Conference
Finals the Golden State Warriors the San
Antonio Spurs
happy heavy underdog
letters with the ball drives and
finishes
a total of 14 Leonard
muscles way inside of scoffers
letter tips away trying to hide
but eight minutes left to go in the
third quarter why do is out of the game
it's an opportunity walk up on day he
took away that baby I think the NBA's
gotta cool that condition this Coast
look a guy has to have space to come
down
which pointers much today
46 to 22 was the run that was gone on
from them
San Antonio couldn't get anything done
if I'm the Spurs when you don't have
your star that's a big concern as a
teammate the atmosphere that they had
with the Spurs and their team chemistry
what it's been for so long for him to
not be a game that's my pop will punish
him for that I'll be surprised if he
returns the season this year they have
not been as dominant as they have been
in the past three or four seasons your
legs are not hurting that bad
I go for the goal gets it right here and
Santa and clap for your teammate
Tony park he's not moving here secretary
Paulson
same kind of injury I might was a
hundred times worse it starts to make us
think about how severe this play
super reporters are reporting that a
wild lender he wants out he wants out of
San Antonio he didn't like what was
going on in how they handled his injury
in San Antonio and he wants to go well
as you all know that's why you're here
traders been made
Hawaiian daddy moving out of Toronto and
Michael Rosen is not the hurdle coming
to San Antonio and taking a chance on a
guy who has told you very specifically
they did not want to be traded to
Toronto can you keep waddling in Toronto
you're getting arguably one of the top
five powers of the MBA you look at that
last you say wow this Eastern Congress
could be wide open maybe this team to
get back to the top of you hopefully
this gonna elevate us as much as we want
you know when the blind gain leaving the
youth then they feel like a favorite to
come out of it but in my estimation
Thailand is the best defenders
investment I mean daga is incredible and
if you asked the superstars in our movie
they may not say it publicly but I
guarantee none of them like me
by quality he is that much of an impact
on the game
conveniently I just feel like he's gonna
do the Pelagos he has to go and impose
Kawhi Leonard to everything
and says anything but here's a bad game
[Music]
look at this you know you can do it on
both ends of the floor and as everybody
they make a run to the keys to confer
finally even the NBA Finals or I really
have to think twice about do I really
want to leave here I know la is real
sunny but the sixth at something for me
it's easy to forget how good quiet it
was
he was the Finals MVP as well that's not
me this is the reason why he was brought
here everybody that question why did
move happen or why a hospital rental
public awhile it this is the reason why
why am be low for him took over the
basketball game they did a nice job
Toronto just grinding this one out
really just trying to play as perfect as
possibly just inches bus early
when you look at his ability to store
he's as efficient is almost anybody else
conservative top super sadly he's the
player of the caliber tech get you over
to home and that's exactly what happened
I got a really good plan
get us baskets when we need them if they
do to get to the NBA Finals very silly
for me to say that the Raptors have no
chance to resign Kawhi Leonard
is Yanis the new LeBron into East be
honest is on his way
I think the Toronto Raptors coach it has
to come down today just gotta compete
well the benches been basically
destroyed by Milwaukee's bench you don't
want to go down 3-0 just gonna win home
and give out the best player want to be
the guys team always said that
and you look at the office and when you
look at the watch the difference is we
shot making the ability of bow eyeliner
and what
opens up think about the gamble that
Masai Ujiri
looks like it's played out pretty well
Toronto Raptors who will be the first
team to hosted NBA Finals outside the
United States the upcoming challenge
that the defending champion warriors
will present in a Champions
the mental focus and
[Music]
congratulations Kauai go celebrate
they got hard and they reckon
Kauai is led them somewhere they've
never been before they have a great
chance to win the series
maybe not done yet man you've got to
step on this Tatar we got that one